P
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO
DO.
>> Laura: THANK YOU, GREAT TO
SEE YOU TONIGHT.
WE TOLD YOU THIS I THINK, THE
WHOLE WEEK ABOUT THE REAL
TERRORISTS, THEY ARE USING
INTIMIDATION AND VIOLENCE, AND
VIOLENT CAMPAIGNS TO THREATEN
ANYBODY WITH WHOM THEY DISAGREE
POLITICALLY.
WE SEE THIS IN THEIR CONTINUED
ATTACK ON PRESIDENCY CENTERS OR
ASSASSINATION ATTEMPTS OF THE
SUPREME COURT, BUT IS THIS NO
CONCERN OF THE DEMOCRATS?
CONGRESSWOMAN JACKIE SPEIER,
HERE SHE WAS TODAY RECOUNTING
HER HARROWING ENCOUNTERS DURING
THE JONESTOWN MASSACRE NEARLY 45
YEARS AGO.
>> I BELIEVE I'M THE ONLY MEMBER
OF THE HOUSE THAT'S A VICTIM OF
GUN VIOLENCE.
MY BODY IS RIDDLED WITH BULLETS.
I LIVE WITH THAT EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
>> Laura: HER ORDEAL WAS
HORRIFIC BUT SHE BREEZED PAST
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED LESS
THAN FIVE AGO.
IF A DERANGED BERNIE SANDERS
SUPPORTER FIRED OFF MORE THAN 60
ROUNDS AND ADD REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES.
FIVE PEOPLE WERE TINGLING IN MY
NEXT GUEST WHO ALMOST DIED.
CONGRESSMAN STEVE SCALISE TURNS
ME NOW
ON THE HEARINGS THAT WERE BEING
HELD, IT WAS CONVENIENT AND I
CAN'T IMAGINE SHE FORGOT WHAT
HAPPENED FIVE YEARS AGO, YOUR
REACTION?
>> LAURA, LOOK, CLEARLY WE KNEW
WHAT HAPPENED.
WHATEVER HER REASON WAS, I THINK
MOST AMERICANS ARE SICK AND
TIRED OF THE POLITICALIZATION TO
CHANGE THE TOPIC.
THEY KNOW WHAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE ANGRY ABOUT.
THEY'RE ANGRY ABOUT WHAT
JOE BIDEN AND NANCY PELOSI AND
THE FAR LEFT SOCIALIST AGENDA
HAVE DONE TO PEOPLE.
THEY WISH CONGRESS WAS
ADDRESSING THOSE THINGS, NOT AN
ATTEMPT TO TAKE AWAY GUNS IT
SEEMS LIKE OVER AND OVER AGAIN
THEY FEEL LIKE THEY CAN BLAME
PUTIN, ANYBODY ELSE, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE SMARTER THAN
THAT.
THEY FIGURED OUT WHO IS THE
CAUSE OF THE PAIN THEIR FAMILIES
AND OUR FAMILIES ARE SUFFERING.
THEY CAN CHANGE THE DIRECTION,
WHAT'S COMING IN NOVEMBER, THEY
ARE SCARED TO DEATH OF BECAUSE
THEY ONLY WANT POWER.
THEY WANT TO SHUT DOWN CITIES.
THEY WANT TO DEFUND THE POLICE.
THEY WANT TO DO THE THINGS THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE TIRED OF AND
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL HAVE
THE FINAL SAY ON NOVEMBER 8TH.
>> Laura: YOU WATCH THE
HEARING TONIGHT AND THE
ATTEMPTED PRODUCTION VALUE,
GOING TO GET INTO THAT WITH
RAYMOND ARROYO, BUT I DON'T KNOW
HOW MUCH ALL OF IT COSTS.
THEY'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR
18 MONTHS.
APPROXIMATELY.
IT CAN'T BE CHEAP AND LAST TIME
I CHECKED THEY WERE KIND OF
BROKE.
GOING TO GRAND CENTRAL STATION,
YOU WILL SEE 30 OR 40 PEOPLE
LIVING ON THE STREETS, CRAWLING
ON THE STREETS, THROWING UP ON
THEMSELVES BECAUSE THEY ARE SO
SICK OR ADDLED WITH DRUGS, I
DON'T KNOW WHICH.
AMERICA IS CRUMBLING ESPECIALLY
IN THE URBAN AREAS.
IT WAS BLOWING MONEY ON THEM AND
FOR WHAT REASON?
>> ONE IMPORTANT QUESTION THAT
WE HAVE ASKED OF THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA TO ASK SPEAKER PELOSI, WHO
PAID THE HOLLYWOOD PRODUCER?
IT'S AGAINST THE LAW TO USE
TAXPAYER FUNDS TO PRODUCE A
DOCUMENTARY TRYING TO PROMOTE
THEIR POLITICAL AGENDA OR GO
AFTER THEIR POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
IF WE HAVE NOT HEARD AN ANSWER.
WHO PAID THIS GUY?
NOT ONLY PRODUCE THE VIDEO, BUT
SUPPOSEDLY COVERED UP FOR
JEFFREY EPSTEIN SO HE'S GOT HIS
OWN TRACK RECORD.
BUT HOW DID HE GET PAID?
HE'S NOT ALLOWED TO GET TAXPAYER
MONEY TO GET PAID AND IF HE DID
IT FOR FREE, THAT'S A
CONTRIBUTION THAT'S ALSO
ILLEGAL.
THE QUESTION OF WHO PAID HIM AND
HOW MUCH DID HE GET PAID AND HOW
DID THAT TRANSACTION OCCUR IS AN
INTERESTING QUESTION BECAUSE
THEY ARE MAY BE OF LAW.
>> Laura: YOU THINK THE
ACTIONS THEMSELVES ON JANUARY 6
WHERE